madonna che sta un po sognando bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video io sono felice io ci
sono su finger potrebbe sembrare una
roba un po sconci no credo
no no è un gioco del 2015 di fatto da
edmund mcmahon e luned mcmahon il
giocatore di domani con isaac quindi
sarà una figata tra l'altro the finger e
un oggetto anche di the binding of isaac
che se punti un nemico li fai danno non
interessava un cazzo a nessuno mai l'ho
detto fin grant è un gioco dove tu
effettive te devi additare le persone
che credi colpevoli basic bob credo il
che che fosse magro a perché lo buttano
sulla sedia legami kutcher di armi di
share
ok quindi è un tipo magro va bene e ho
capito allora non è questo non è questo
potrebbe essere questo qua l'elite
lipton potrebbe essere anche marcio mac
che non è così ma ciò ho anche brinkley
willis andiamo sul secondo indizio
sembrava vecchio beh effettivamente non
è che si capisca chi è vecchio chi no è
però questo è già più vecchio di questo
ok questo qua quindi a quel punto nel
numero uno tra basso quindi se la
giocano tutti e due
non so cosa voglia dire però questo è
vecchio quelle giovane thing vegas alla
madonna po ingrato lection addirittura
vi sembra un po eccessivo come gioco
però va bene near saitech merci tra i
service ho detto ma cosa hanno fatto
questi uomini cattivi
sembrava piccolo quindi gli ultimi due
li buttiamo questo qua è questo qua
potrebbero essere ok
sembrava che avesse perso i capelli
quindi questo e quello è un cappuccio
sono capelli
quello è un cappuccio anche questo però
lo è merda tutte e due sono senza
capelli allora hanno questo celiache
pirla questo non cediamo però proviamo
così ragazze liberiamo le gare affinché
non tiro la leva proprio non succede
niente che brutta cosa ma mi dispiace
aver laica o no innocente man era un
uomo innocente bigot barney è razzista
ma la cosa cazzo sto leggere sembrava
uno gnomo
ma che cazzo ne sono scusi questo lo
gnomo fiorai di carroll giulio a caso a
caso come a casa entro 100 membri quello
ti sembra uno gnomo
a me non sembra uno nuovo però
proviamoci dai atti fa ripartire da zero
ok all andavo a caso per po diverso un
po di suspence specie nice and child
non so cosa voglio dire sembra pulini
ten tiley penso voglia dire pulito ha
pulito e profumato ok
questi non sono puliti e profumati solo
uno
sono 2 o 3 1 2 e 3 ok sono puliti e
profumati andiamo profumati non lo so
puliti sicuro giunchi cianchi vuol dire
grosso pulito profumato e grosso questo
è grosso
ok sembrava basso queste grosse basso
sembrava pelato e anche questo è pelato
però a una sorta di cappellino sotto gli
occhiali e un capello subito quindi
questo per forza my lai e lui lo e
vengono mercato va bene amati dice anche
che ok dice anche che le prove sono il
60 per cento corrette
ok qui non è tutto vero quello che ti
dicono va bene sembrava pulito ok quindi
escludiamo tutti tranne l'ultimo è
questo qua che sembra un pò tra quella
bellodi barnabas sembrava alto ok cool
charles non sembrava aver perso i
capelli quindi questo qui è tutto
sembrava anche un po oscuro lui è molto
più sicuro però mi fido del fatto che
non ha perso i capelli quindi lui
ma.ro ma spero non è pulito quello è
tutto meno che pulito bigot barney e
razzista va bene sembrava brutto non
ragazzi non ne vedo uno bello ma non
neanche base mi impegno ne vedo uno
bello non sembrava decisamente pelato va
bene e quindi non è pelato non mi sta
aiutando per niente sembrava un gigante
[Musica]
questo non è non è pelato sono girate
qui che questo è brutto sicuramente non
sembrava definiti definitivamente una
persona che io odio quindi non può
essere non essendo razzista non è una
persona di colore però questa cosa non
ha senso perché questo è brutto uguale
che cazzo ne so io regalo o la citazione
va bene negative nancy lei è sempre
negativa va bene decisamente non
sembrava uno scheletro uguali sembra uno
scheletro questo sembra uno scheletro
diceva bene quindi escludiamo il numero
3 non sembrava il proprietario di casa
ma cosa ma che cazzo c'entra non era
pelato ok quindi questo dei capelli
questo voi capelli questo coi capelli
quello c'è una merda a previtali casa
perché questo è un nomade ok quindi lui
cento per cento e non sembra piccole lui
perché c'è la sauna bio rafa team del
ogni tanto sbaglia qualcosa merda va
bene
sembrava uno scheletro ma sarò vale lo
scheletro e non l'ho capita ragazzi che
cazzo vuol dire non sembrava decisamente
come se avesse dei soldi va bene allora
questo quali sola città help potrei
all'ultimo e per forza lui allora io la
provo con due raga la provo con due non
vado neanche avanti vediamo
con due ma donna bellissima vivo le è di
addio all solo la metà sono vere
ok minchia questa difficile come faccia
come faccio
posso rilasciare gente a per darmi una
mano ok
e però poi non la posso di buttare
dentro che uno show se hanno giocato
speriamo non fosse lui sono sicuro che
sembrava una femmina ma lui che lui se
che lui sembrava femmina quindi non è
non è a femminile ok femminile sembrava
pelato non sembrava il il mio tipo di
ragazzo che cazzo ne so io non sembrava
brutto non sono per niente non mi aiuta
niente di quello che ho chiesto niente
potrebbe essere qualsiasi cosa ragazzi
perché abbiamo il cinquanta per cento di
sbaglio lo sapevo la l'altro porca
[ __ ] l'altro 50 per cento e lo
sbaglio il 50 per cento incredibile ma
vera gare è veramente il gioco più
strano che io abbia mai fatto nella mia
vita dal creatore di the binding of
isaac tra l'altro è famosissimo gioco
però non l'avevo mai fatto ci voleva un
episodio comunque spero che ve ne sia
piaciuto questa raffigurerà è stato
veramente strangio era finger ed arrivo
fino al livello 6 poi con i voletti
perdo non chiedetevi perché questo è un
mi piace anche a vari social che ogni
nota descrizione se lo sarebbe sfide è
che come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza
[Musica]